when you look at the people that have
done this role and this role
specifically it's like stepping into
Hamlet it really is and I've actually
said that exact same thing on the very
first interview I did for the Joker I
compared it to taking on Hamlet yeah
because it's been interpreted and
reinterpreted so well so many times by
such talented people it is there's a
there's a weight that comes along with
it a responsibility and an expectation
you have a great head of hair but thank
you so much gonna see the same thing
about you no no you have a great head of
hair I'm just pretending this is a
moment where for years I got it from an
older actor I'm not going to tell you
who oh really oh yeah his name rhymes
with with bumble bee right when when
heat Ledger did the Joker fans of The
Joker universally agreed that this was
amazing when you started to take this on
how much of that still sort of thing did
you do and yet try and still make it
your own to not disappoint fans to not
go too far from what from what Heath had
done Heath gave a perfect performance
yeah he it's one of the best
performances ever on screen not just as
a villain but just performances I think
it's beautiful and I have so much
respect for it I knew both Heath and
Jack's performance which is brilliant
mark hamill says our Romero they've all
given such brilliant unforgettable
performances I knew you you couldn't go
anywhere near it you had to walk down a
completely different path and that's
what was great about having those
performances but the inspiration that I
took from all of these actors and these
performances is the fearlessness yeah
how brave they were how they threw
themselves into the role and how much
opportunity there was when you are that
guy when you are the Joker what is it
like for the people in your life like do
you break and call them to be like hey
have a great weekend or what is it like
for the people in your life when you're
Oh inside for me I wanted to stay as
committed and as focused as I could to
really push away any distractions it was
an opportunity to work as hard as I
possibly could you know I didn't walk
around thinking I was someone else you
know but but it's interesting when you
commit in that way it changes the way
other people interact with you right so
that's really powerful to see how people
start to behave around this you know
legendary character and there are number
different reasons to take this kind of
approach that are really informative but
for me it was just about commitment yeah
since since Academy Award time you've
always been very I don't want to say
picky but very sort of picky with what
you do you don't turn them out as a lot
of other movies in nine years you can
say I'm a little picky with what you
you're a little picky with what you do
have you become more so or less so since
since Dallas buyers and Academy Award
time I think I took about five and a
half years away from films before Dallas
yeah and I've made one film since I
believe I made that movie in 2012-13 and
came out came out at the end of 13 the
Academy Awards were 14 yeah yeah so I
guess yeah it's already been quite some
time so I'm good for like one every four
years all right
but you will do Joker again you're going
to miss me if I never go we will do
Joker again right if people like the
performance yes and if they respond to
it I would love to come back and if they
don't if they reject it and they don't
like it I'll just be in a cabin in the
woods right fair enough thank you
Thanks